هنا ازمه جديده قديمه تطل على الحدود بين
افغانستان وباكستان
والعنصر المشترك فيها طالبان حيث تصاعد
التوتر الحدودي منذ استولى الطالبان على
السلطه اذ اتهمت اسلام اباد مجموعات مسلحه
بشنها جمال متكرره من الاراضي الافغانيه
وتنفي حركه طالبان ايواء مقاتلين
باكستانيين اما التوام الايديولوجي
لطالبان في باكستان الجماعه التي تضم تحت
لوائها مسلحين مرتبطين بحركه طالبان التي
تحكم افغانستان فقد انهت وقفه اطلاق نار
استمر لاشهر مع الحكومه الباكستانيه الشهر
الماضي
ونفذت موته هجمات في انحاء البلاد انتهاء
وقف اطلاق النار في باكستان لا يهدد
بتصعيد العنف في هذا البلد فحسب بل يهدد
ايضا
بزياده التوتر عبر الحدود بين البلدين
افغانستان وباكستان
باكستان منذ ايام اعلنت عزمها شنغارات
عسكريه على معاقل الحركه مشيره الى ان ذلك
يقع ضمن نطاق القانون الدولي كما عينت
اسلام اباد قبل فتره مسؤولا عسكريا جديدا
على درايه تامه بحركه طالبان باكستان
وجغرافيتها في حين ان الحركه ومنذ مجيء
شهباز شريف كثفت منها هجماتها ضد الحكومه
اما واشنطن التي سبق وصنفت حركه طالبان
باكستان على انها منظمه ارهابيه لا تنفك
تذكر مرارا وتكرارا خلال الفتره الماضيه
انه يمكن استهداف طالبان باكستان وقادتها
قلق يتفجر من تفاقم الاوضاع عقب الانهيار
الاخير لوقف اطلاق النار المهتز بالفعل
بين طالبان باكستان واسلام اباد